hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter 11 of his book the selfish
gene richard dawkins
is going to introduce what he thinks to
be a new concept that of the meme
and he's bringing in this notion to
help develop an explanation for cultural
transmission and what looks like a kind
of evolution
that he says we can observe historically
that
is not able to be adequately
conceptualized and articulated
by thinking things through in a
darwinist perspective that
relies primarily on some
older and well-attested notions
and so we're talking about cultural
transmission and evolution as something
that's distinctive to human beings other
animals do
engage in this to a certain extent but
it's observed and oftentimes promoted by
human beings rather than
being something really central to their
existence with a few exceptions
now dawkins thinks that
as a good darwinist he's going to have
to
go beyond the basis that a lot of other
darwinists have used
to try to explain cultural evolution
many
like to appeal to genes or to group
selection
or biological advantage and the idea
here is that they say
listen some things like believing in god
or
the conception of you know punishment
after death
or you know romantic love pick whatever
it is that you like those are things
that um are good for the group and
therefore
wind up being reproduced as as such you
know
charles not just charles darwin
darwin is more concerned about
biological entities but he does talk
a bit about like the emotions and things
like that but herbert spencer would be a
prime example of that group selection
thing
other people actually said no it was
just jeans actually you know
being cheerful uh having a gene for that
will actually make you
fit in the group better and you're more
likely to get a mate and pass that on
being more rose and sulky maybe that has
an evolutionary disadvantage
and dawkins says listen these sort of
things are putting the cart before the
horse
and they don't provide good explanations
we can't base this just on biological
advantage of the organism as such we
have to have a different
kind of explanation so let's go back to
first principles and he does do that
and in the process he says there's
analogies between
genes genetic reproduction and memes
these
cultural units of reproduction they both
have the you know what makes them
special
is replication imitation he also says
that's why where he gets the word meme
from meme
and so replicating themselves dna
molecules
replicate themselves and so do
cultural units like this
what what are the key features of this
replication he talks about
longevity fecundity for kennedy means
the
uh productiveness you could say or the
fertility
and then copying fidelity which makes it
be the same meme
you if it's copying things but they look
nothing like what you're copying you're
not really copying you're just making
things instead
and so these three features he thinks
are connected with each other they play
out differently
genes perhaps have much better copying
fidelity
than do memes or perhaps we have to
rethink
what copying fidelity looks like they
both have
spaces of reproduction that take place
over time with genes it's you know
all the genetic material that goes into
dna and the chromosomes right
and they're made up of of physical
elements and you could say
aren't uh memes also i mean if they
occupy
space in our brains neurons are physical
things yes
but there's something that goes beyond
the merely physical whatever we want to
call it
and the spaces of reproduction for memes
are
our brain space but also public space
where we convey meaning to each other he
uses
the example of billboards which are
still around interestingly
they've and some billboards have gone
digital right they change their thing as
your driving past
he brings up newspapers we might bring
up logs
we might also bring up video sites and
podcast sites as
places where memes are being propagated
perhaps even
new memes are being generated right and
so
the spaces of reproduction are very
important
for understanding how memes work and
then you know to take one example he
talks about women's fashion and
specifically high-heeled shoes
and now is that being reproduced in
guitar magazine probably not is it being
reproduced in cosmopolitan
probably so is it being reproduced
in the displays that gets sent out to
you
in the form of you know newspapers that
almost everybody throws away that wind
up in your mailbox
perhaps so right these are all important
aspects and then we get to a much
more interesting and worthy of further
discussion
issue which is complexes
how should we understand what counts as
a gene or understands as
a meme and he says that
you know we we can think i appeal to the
same verbal trick
i used in chapter three i divided the
gene complex into large
and small genetic units and units within
units the gene in quotes was defined
not in a rigid all or one none way but
as a unit of convenience a length of
chromosome with just enough sufficient
copying fidelity
to serve as a viable unit of natural
selection and then he says if a single
phrase of beethoven's ninth symphony
is sufficiently distinctive and
memorable to be abstracted
from the context of the whole symphony
and uses the call sign of a matting
mattingly intrusive european
broadcasting system
then to that extent it deserves to be
called one meme
it has incidentally materially
diminished my capacity to enjoy
the original symphony so he's willing to
say that memes can be
broken down but they can also be
built up into entire complexes and this
is going to turn out to be
something quite important that comes up
in relation to another discussion that
he has of the connection between
these two so he says throughout this
book i've emphasized we
must not think of genes as conscious
purposeful agents blind natural
selection
makes them behave as if they were
purpose purposeful
and it's been convenient to refer to
genes in the language of purpose for
example to call them
selfish which is a you know
anthropological
term so when he says genes are when we
say genes are trying to increase their
numbers in future gene pools
we don't actually mean that they're like
thinking how can i increase my
numbers they're behaving in such a way
as to have the effect of increasing
their numbers in future
gene pools and he says just as we found
it convenient to think of genes
as active agents working purposefully
for their own survival
maybe we should think of memes
in the same way we don't have to get
mystical purpose is only a metaphor
but it's a fruitful metaphor so if we're
going to say that then we can call
memes ruthless or selfish
and we can say that they come into
competition
with each other and what we're saying
there is just that they
happen to crowd each other out that they
happen to
replace each other collide with each
other to occupy
the same spaces to try to well actually
the tri
is already a purposeful word but they
they attempt to
attempt as a synonym see how hard it is
to get away from this sort of
lingo they do whatever they're going to
do
to maximize their use of resources which
ends up minimizing
others or vice versa and so they do come
into competition and
this is where we can talk about the
spaces of replication right
if beethoven's symphony ninth symphony
is stuck in my head on continual loop
then perhaps i can't have another
classical symphony
or a pop song or bits of a lecture that
i heard
also in my head on continual loop
right so memes can push each other out
can take over
space and this is you know why he's
saying that there's cultural evolution
you know we don't use some of the same
language for slaying as we would have
back in the day you know say watch a
movie from the 1930s
they talk in ways that we say are corny
actually we don't even say the word
corny anymore
that's an older meme isn't it now we say
cringeworthy or something
like that so they can come into compet
they can come into competition with each
other
he also talks about how memes and genes
themselves
as classes of things might come into
opposition with each other and he brings
up
uh celibacy specifically celibacy
on the part of priests a gene that would
promote
celibacy because celibacy has to do with
not
reproducing physically not having sex
right
would seem to be self-defeating
a meme however for celibacy
on the part of at least some people for
example certain religious
leaders or religious profess
professionals you might think about
monks and nuns he he has in mind priests
here but let's think about monks and
nuns because they've had a much bigger
influence
throughout the history in terms of
celibacy oftentimes priests could
actually be married and in many
religions they still can
and are even expected to be monks and
nuns
in you know hinduism jainism buddhism
christianity
are expected to be celibate but they're
often tasked with important
functions within the religious community
that not having at least in theory
physical sexual romantic relationships
would distract them from
and as meme producers
and as meme transmitters perhaps they
have a greater efficacy
by not getting it on with anybody right
so that's a
great example and dawkins
here comes into an interesting
conjecture
maybe what he's calling co-adapted
meme complexes where you've got a whole
bunch of different things
reinforcing each other maybe those
things evolve
like gene complexes do what are what are
examples of gene complexes
developing a certain kind of teeth that
go along with a certain kind of
elementary canal and perhaps even you
know could say co-adaptation with
certain bacteria
within your gut and certain
other things like these handy-dandy as
aristotle called it the hands the tool
of tools right maybe all while in big
brains that can
think out these things maybe those all
go together
right maybe other gene complexes work
really well in other animals maybe it's
the same thing
for co-adapted meme
complexes so when we're thinking about
music again
for example or fashion or architecture
there would be a bunch of traits that
all accompany each other
and over time maybe some of them fall
out and get replaced
but they tend to cohere as a whole
in which case we can think of them as a
single meme or we can think of them as a
complex now dawkins finishes
this discussion by raising a very
interesting idea
he says who is actually the subject
here who is the adaptation
and reproduction working for is it
working for the
bearer of the traits the human being the
person walking down the street
whistling you know the the kiss song or
van halen song in their head or pick
whatever pop song of the present
you're into if you're not into classic
heavy metal um
no and here he suggests something very
interesting
maybe cultural traits memes
evolved simply to be advantageous to
themselves
to replicate themselves using us
and our actions our desires our
decisions
our communication as a medium
now this is quite speculative and goes
kind of far beyond and it would
it would require us also to buy into
this kind of purpose language
but perhaps that is part of the effect
of what dawkins hear is calling memes
maybe this is another way that they're
similar to but also
in some respect a jump beyond
the slow evolving genes
you